en los vídeos pasados ya vimos algunos
ejemplos de elasticidad acá arriba
teníamos una curva de demanda lineal y
de todas formas la elasticidad iba
cambiando cada vez iba disminuyendo en
valor absoluto y acá abajo teníamos
ejemplos de dpt ciertos bienes que eran
perfectamente inelásticos o bien
perfectamente elásticos lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es seguir explorando
la elasticidad y ahora vamos a pensar en
cómo se vería la curva de demanda la
curva de demanda de un bien que tiene
elasticidad constante y bueno para hacer
las cosas un poco más concretas vamos a
suponer que tiene elasticidad siempre
igual a 1 entonces déjame ponerle por
aquí elasticidad unitaria vale
elasticidad y equidad
unitaria unitaria entonces el chiste es
que ahora en toda la curva de demanda
vamos a tener elasticidad igual a 1
déjame poner unos ejes para ver esto
para ir explorando esta idea entonces
ahí tengo un eje ahí tengo otro eje de
este lado a la izquierda tengo el precio
aquí abajo tengo la cantidad y vamos a
ponerle algunos numeritos vamos a
ponerle que por aquí es 10 que por acá
es 10 también y más o menos que por aquí
es 1 y por aquí es una va más o menos
así es tal escala ok entonces vamos a
pensar que esta curva de demanda que
ahorita voy a dibujar o que vamos a
empezar a dibujar algunos puntitos tiene
elasticidad unitaria eso quiere decir
que el valor absoluto de la elasticidad
de la elasticidad de la demanda es igual
a 1 vale ahora como esta de aquí es una
curva de demanda entonces tiene
pendiente negativa o sea estamos
suponiendo que se satisface la ley de la
demanda entonces pedir que la
elasticidad de la demanda sea igual a a
uno en valor absoluto es pedir que la
elasticidad de la demanda sea igual
al menos uno hay otra opción verdad pudo
haber sido uno pero no lo es por la ley
de la demanda bueno esto qué quiere
decir en porcentajes esto básicamente en
porcentaje lo que quiere decir es que un
cambio porcentual en el precio nos va a
ser el mismísimo cambio porcentual en la
cantidad pero hacia abajo o sea si el
precio aumenta en 10 por ciento la
cantidad va a disminuir en un 10% vale
entonces vamos a empezar a ver la forma
de esta curva de demanda vamos a
tomarnos algunos puntos entonces déjame
empezar con este punto de acá cuando la
cantidad es 1 cuando la cantidad es 1
supongamos que el precio es igual a 10 y
cuando la cantidad es diez supongamos
que el precio es igual a 1 pero
utilizando esta información como se
tendría que ver esta curva de demanda
pues ve aquí la cantidad es 1 así que si
hacemos un cambio porcentual de digamos
10% si nos vamos a 1.1 1.1 entonces el
precio también tiene que bajar en 10 por
ciento pero 10% de 10 es más que 10% de
1 10% de 10 es pues toda una unidad
completa verdad entonces aquí la curva
tiene que bajar
así como muy rápidamente bueno entonces
aquí bajó muy rápidamente el cambio
porcentual en el precio fue de 1 y el
cambio porcentual en la cantidad pues o
sea en total fue de punto 1 si el 10% de
12.1 muy bien ahora vámonos para acá
vámonos al otro extremo qué pasa si la
cantidad es 10 y ahora el precio es 1
pues de modo similar vamos a pensar qué
sucede con un cambio de 10% o sea si
cambiamos en 10% la cantidad
digamos hacia acá ahora esto se
convierte en 9 verdad disminuye 9 pero
como la elasticidad de la demanda es
menos 1 aquí tuvimos un cambio de menos
10% y por tanto el cambio en el precio
debe de ser de 10% aquí estamos en 1 el
cambio en el precio es de 10% llegamos a
1.1 si verdad porque justo a la
elasticidad de la demanda quizás sería
bueno escribir eso pero la elasticidad
de la demanda justo la definimos como un
cambio porcentual cambio porcentual en
la cantidad entre el cambio porcentual
cambio porcentual y en el precio
entonces básicamente lo que he estado
haciendo aquí
aquí es poner que esto es 10 por ciento
o que esto es 10 por ciento y entonces
el otro correspondientemente pues es
menos 10 por ciento sale bueno vámonos
para acá para seguir con esta idea
entonces si el precio y la cantidad
disminuye en 10 por ciento o bien si el
precio aumenta en 10 por ciento aquí que
es punto 1 la cantidad se mueve menos 1
y entonces ahora la curva de demanda y
por esta área de acá se tendría que ver
más o menos así más o menos así y más o
menos así ok vamos a trazar un punto más
algo un poco más intermedio digamos más
o menos por 5 y aquí también tenemos 5
aquí cómo se vería mira aquí se vio como
muy inclinada y aquí ya no está tan
inclinada está más o menos horizontal
aquí en el 5 que tendríamos que hacer
está pues en el 5 un cambio porcentual
de 10% es irnos a 5.5 digamos y un
cambio porcentual en el precio es decir
nos a 4.5 o viceversa verdad si tenemos
un 4.5 acá nos movemos aquí a un 5.5
entonces aquí lo que sucede es que el
cambio se ve igualito entonces el cambio
o sea la recta nos quedaría
como una como una recta así inclinada a
45 grados de esta forma vamos a unir los
puntos para ver qué nos queda bueno
vamos a unir estas tres regiones estas
tres secciones más bien debería decir y
entonces más o menos al principio tiene
que bajar muy rápido la curva de demanda
luego tiene que más o menos bajar como
con 45 grados de aquí a la mitad y luego
bajar más lento entonces más o menos más
o menos deberían déjame hacerla un poco
más bonita la voy a hacer con punteada
porque es más fácil hacerlo así entonces
más o menos se vería como algo así como
algo así baja
luego aquí bajas y luego llega este
punto y empieza a pegarse más y más al
eje horizontal muy bien entonces más o
menos se parece como un cachito de una
hipérbola pero ahorita no me quiero
meter con las cuentas de cada cálculo ni
de álgebra ya si la cosa es que al
principio baja muy rápido esa curva de
demanda y luego se empieza a hacer más y
más horizontal entonces así se vería la
curva de demanda de un cierto bien que
tiene elasticidad unitaria constante